ils ont entre 30 et 50 ans les week-ends
à la datcha
ils connaissent pas les russes de new
york préfère les boîtes de nuit aux
maisons de campagne il vendredi au
dimanche ils squattent les clubs de
brooklyn à manhattan
[Musique]
les nuits russes et des jeunes filles on
se marre on picole on danse on s'éclate
prendre du bon temps les clubbers russe
new yorkais sont passés maîtres en la
matière
la plupart d'entre eux ont grandi dans
l'austérité de l'autre côté du rideau de
fer dans les années 80 alors maintenant
comme dj pouchkine aux platines le
dancefloor leur appartient ici on est
vraiment loin de la russie on est plus
en russie
on est aux états unis à new york à
brooklyn les russes
réveillez vous
m
salut les gars bienvenue entrée
quand il n'est pas en boîte dj pouchkine
travail chez lui c'est mon jouet favori
son appartement ressemble un studio
d'enregistrement
sais-tu crânien de 35 ans a fait des
nuits slave son business multicartes il
est producteur de musique et de clips et
organisateur de fêtes du mariage à la
soirée string vous voyez là c'est
l'élite de la communauté russe en
amérique
ses clients sont tous issus de la
diaspora russe est en général demande
pas d'argent
un mariage facture à peu près dix mille
dollars
dj pouchkine ou lieu chat pour les
intimes a eu son premier walkman à 14
ans il était temps l'ukraine un fana de
musique et d'image [ __ ] sous l'ère
communiste sa revanche aujourd'hui c'est
son job
on a des filles qui dansent à moitié nue
j'adore ça quand j'avais 6 ans ma grand
tante qui habitait déjà aux états unis
avaient envoyé un blouson c'était le
plus merveilleux des cadeaux parce qu en
ukraine en russie tout était fabriquée
par le gouvernement tous se ressembler
et tout est vraiment moche en 89 c'est
la révolution pour lui aux chats ils
quittent kiev avec ses parents pour new
york à brighton beach plus précisément
maintenant je vous emmène découvrir le
quartier russe de brighton beach
[Musique]
brighton beach c'est le coeur de la
communauté russe américaine à la fin des
années soixante dix le quartier au sud
de brooklyn devient la terre d'accueil
de tout ce qui fut le communisme l
antisémitisme
[Musique]
avant la chute du mur personne ne
pouvait quitter la russie la règle
c'était tu vis ici tu es soviétique
tu restes ici tu ne vas pas aux états
unis on n'aime pas les états unis c'est
un pays capitaliste qui tire profit de
son peuple
c'est mal c'était vraiment la pire des
conneries l'idée la plus stupide
les vagues d'immigration se sont succédé
aujourd'hui près de 500000 russe livre à
new york
et tous ont mis les pieds au moins une
fois ici sur la promenade de little
odessa l'autre nom du quartier
je vends voiles océan atlantique
c'est pour ça que les gens originaires
de dessin ont atterri ici c'était le
meilleur endroit pour eux parce que ça
leur rappeler les bords de la mer noire
la nostalgie du pays quoi
[Musique]
côté boulevard on sent aussi le poids
des années brick crasse boutique sur
année le choeur de little odessa
appartient à une génération de migrants
révolue
ok ça c'est un des magasins russes de
dvd entré lui c'est vladimir le proprio
son frère et et ici il est venu le
rejoindre dès qu'il a pu quitter la
russie les mots aujourd'hui les gens qui
arrivent c'est juste parce qu'ils en ont
envie notre vague d'immigration à nous
elle était purement politique
c'était la dernière d'ailleurs liocha
enfants de la dernière vague d'immigrés
politique n'a pas franchement le mal du
pays
pourtant curieux paradoxe sa communauté
ici ressemble à s'y méprendre à l'union
soviétique de la grande époque
demain il viendra mixer pour
l'inauguration du restaurant d'un vieil
ami originaire d'ouzbékistan
ici on est tous mélangés tu viennes
d'ukraine une béquille ce temps ou
d'arménie se sont tous du même quoi
c'est pour ça que c'est important que
chacun apporte un peu de sa culture
c'est ça la richesse de la diaspora on
est tous unis et d'ouzbeks plus
d'ukrainiens
ici on est russe fin de journée sur
little odessa
ici les générations se croisent les
enfants des premiers migrants du début
du 20e siècle les exclus du bloc de
l'est
les bannis de la pérestroïka grâce à ses
trois grandes vagues d'immigration l'âme
slave n'est pas près de s'éteindre
[Musique]
good evening ruciak il est minuit vous
êtes dans les locaux de radio positive
aux platines liocha est re devenu dj
pouchkine avec son pote genia animateurs
monté sur ressort c'est parti pour cinq
heures de direct à la vitamine russie du
fond de leur studio les deux animateurs
font vivre les folles nuits russe à
leurs auditeurs sont en contact toute la
nuit avec une escouade de fêtards la
brigade de la fête qui sillonnent les
soirées de la ville de oaxaca jenca
boucle d'or la voilà à l'autre bout du
fil
l'animatrice de notre brigade festive
fils en limousine vers une boîte
branchée de manhattan un jet setteur
russe invite tout ce petit monde à faire
la promo de sa soirée
à l'intérieur l'ambiance est tout aussi
bouillante que la veille terminé le
temps de la rigueur
les 5 heures du mat l'heure est au
bling-bling décomplexée dans la chaleur
de la nuit qu'il semble loin le temps de
la guerre froide
[Musique]
super
c'est la bio en qui ben ali
central park au coeur de manhattan une
scène surréaliste
c'est ici que les corses de new york se
donnent rendez-vous pour chanter les
paniers les les chants polyphoniques de
leur île natale
parmi eux michel il vit ici depuis 25
ans pourtant difficile pour lui
d'assumer le regard des autres
j'aimerais bien qu'on ne soit plus
nombreux à suivre la chose ensemble
comme ça on est plus à être ridicule et
moi on a un petit peu moins rentrer
parce que là je grince à l'intérieur je
peux pas te dire le corse a justement
très très peur du ridicule
voilà c'est simple en fait on est dans
une faille de la tradition corse ici
c'est à dire on oublie le
perfectionnisme on se lance
mais en même temps on partage la
mercuriale n'a pas peur d'irriter ses
voix la sélection corse et d'audace
américaine voire à extraordinaire
michel n'est pas tout à fait comme les
200 autres corses de new york lui est
millionnaire
il a fait fortune dans l'immobilier et
c'est dans le quartier de harlem qu'il
incite ses compatriotes à investir
l'intégration de nos compatriotes corses
est très facile parce que c'est un
village c'est un village avec un
sentiment de fierté c'est plus calme
architecturalement il ya une véritable
harmonie je pense que la fierté du corps
l'esprit défensif du corse est quelque
chose de très voisines à rome c'est donc
russie en plein coeur de harlem que
michel a posé ses valises
bienvenue au temple m un petit bout de
course de 1000 mètres carrés répartis
sur quatre étages nous accueillent c'est
un espace que j'ai acheté il ya six ans
et il ya eu six ans de rénovation sans
cesse j'ai toujours une équipe qui
travaille dessus et voilà c'était une
ancienne église
le cri scientiste je vous fais rentrer
dans mon espace privé aïe ça va plus
être privé là il ya 250 m² de chant la
chambre fait 250 métal alors brillé donc
feu de cheminée là bas au fond un petit
tapis méditation yoga ici michel est
membre actif de l'association des corses
de new york ce soir comme chaque semaine
il reçoit quelques compatriotes
l'occasion de se pencher sur le tout
nouveau facebook de la communauté il ya
quelques semaines il 247 personnes
donc ça reste en sont à niort développés
et ce sont des noms corse ou leonelli
bord sont nés gambarelli forcené j'ai
entendu ça caen n'a par ailleurs pas
coutume harkis battesti deal fantastique
c'est tous nos potes
au menu ce soir qu'à briller copa claire
l'ami de
michel a apporté des canistrelli le
repas peut enfin commencer
je discute avec anne américain et la
passion classique ou iphone et je
réponds à une fois the most beautiful
island alors au dessus de la plus belle
île du bout du monde et non sept mois ce
but il faut la même au bout du monde
impossible pour un natif de l'île de
beauté de ne pas se flatter et l'info du
soir c'est un corse qui a découvert
l'amérique savoir est ce que dans les
autres villages de corse
on revendique christophe colomb parce
que nous on sait que christophe colomb
est menée à calvi donc on sait la maison
je la connais d'ailleurs les temps vente
non je rigole
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
le lendemain matin finie la rigolade
avec les copains michel enfilé son
costume de promoteurs immobiliers et
nous allons rencontrer les ca au sixième
étage lit ça c'est la fille de l'un de
ses riches amis corses
michel doit lui faire visiter un
penthouse une luxueuse propriété sur les
toits de harlem terrasse en tueuse au
sommet darlas puisque en fait on ne peut
plus construire douze étages il y a
quelques années michel a flairé le bon
filon
il a investi lorsque l'ancien maire de
new york rudolph giuliani à nettoyer les
rues de harlem de la drogue et de la
prostitution les chambres sont en
général très grande là on a à peu près à
85 m² pour deux chambres les corses
achète à new york parce que new york
c'est un endroit intelligent à l'achat
de toute façon on est dans la ville la
plus impolie tive des capitales du monde
depuis quelques années les prix ont
doublé à harlem atteignant 8500 $ du
mètre carré
mais pour michel et ses amis corses
l'ancien ghetto black demeure toujours
un placement en or
c'est vrai que pour lisa a démarré avec
un bon achat à natacha intelligent lui
permettra de gagner beaucoup plus
d'argent que n'importe quel métier
qu'elle suivra retour à central park à
new york l'empiré immobilier de michel
ne cesse de croître
heureusement sa folie des grandeurs n'a
jamais altéré son humour et c'est bien
connu
l'humour est le propre des corses
tous ces immeubles c'est vraiment les
symboles phalliques d'une sorte de
guéguerre entre promoteurs à qui aura le
droit de construire l'immeuble le plus
haut et [ __ ] en dessus et le sanglant
de leur personnalité
regarder un petit peu tout ça on sait
tout de suite si vous n'avez pas des
jets d'eau en haut des sommets de new
york
c'est non